[Music]
goodbye mr cookie president electing a
cookie as a president why would you like
anyone or anything that you know for a
fact will eventually crumble also that's
not a cookie that's a wafer and i will
need you to kindly get out of here with
that nonsense how does this universe
work the camera is candy the mic is
candy the gun silencer is candy and the
lollipop appears to be a candy weapon of
some sort so why would a gun or a sword
be an actual weapon and not some other
form of candy i'm not sure which is more
convenient the morty somehow had
thousands of gallons of water readily
available to dump on a lava monster that
he knew precisely where the lava monster
would be or the portal gun itself i'll
send all three son of a [ __ ] he marked
it how is morty just now seeing this i
assumed the portal gun had some sort of
scientific woo-woo that would zippity
zap a portal to life after activating
the portal juice but apparently just
falling onto skin activates a portal
just fine we find out in a moment that
the opposite side of morty's hand portal
is not connected to a garbage dump but
rather the leg of a stranger for this
amount of garbage to pour through nick's
thigh he must be buried in trash but he
isn't hey how do you think i feel i had
the ultimate stash hole and now i got a
kid in my thigh first world problems
good luck finding someone that can be
told 80 000 times how replaceable they
are anyone who has ever worked in a call
center oh look a failed attempt at the
humorous pull nondescript lever to do
something incredibly specific cliche
good thing it didn't land on gene
because we know he's dead from that
other episode this season and when we
pointed it out before everyone agreed
with us and no one called us out on it
so i'm sure that won't happen here
simultaneous crow snatching is severely
questionable commence bird on a wire
scene does not contain a goldie hawn or
mel gibson also when did rick even train
them for this he literally just caught
them outside and brought them in here to
begin pavloving them with the bird feed
damn just like jackie chan i've always
said my favorite jackie chan move is the
one where the broom comes out of the
portal in his hand classic chan
convenient escape route through the only
window on an otherwise windowless
building is convenient damn it he must
be showing the gun off to his stupid
crows it's not fair kids
also i like surprise gun hidey holes as
much as the next person but this secret
cabinet should have been easily spotted
below the table based on how high it
lifts not drinking enough water pee
clear people morty is that what i think
it is the perfectly convenient
appearance of the very item you were
looking for what is that nothing i find
it odd that the game wheel is the first
thing the crows fixate on rather than
the anti-crow graffiti all over the
walls not now garbage goober get back in
your hole rick is a dick to garbage
goober first adventure discounting the
psychiatric hospital as an adventure
that's not how extinguished and
discarded cigarettes work i know we're
not supposed to question how rick's
magical scientific things do their
bullsh but his arm goes a really long
way and i just don't understand where
the mechanical bits are stored when not
in use pressing something to your face
that is dirtier than a toilet seat
you don't get it do you how you were
able to secure a jet pack and how you've
already mastered it in this short amount
of time no no i do not i i thought we
were both victims of rick's abuse
thinking that mutual abuse means mutual
friendship also how did nick track morty
being portal buddies doesn't mean
they're automatically portal tracking
buddies does it how does any of this
episode work
morty survives this for getting to clasp
your safety harness and sure he's
missing a hand but he didn't even try to
secure it with the functional one he has
left lucky for me abandonment to my
bread and butter if rick had the
multi-gun attachment why didn't he lead
with that when he first got on the ship
you were supposed to die then maybe next
time kill rick when you have the drop on
him instead of tying him up so you can
bondly expose it your plan [ __ ]
humanoid crows i'll always be your
grandpa morty i'm just kind of obsessed
with crows now abandoning your grandson
due to a crow fetish this would mean a
lot more if i didn't already know there
were more seasons left in there not
changing the theme of the show to simply
morty or rick and crow rick will be back
there will be a reset none of this means
anything this is a rick and two crows of
lies i suppose one might think i'm about
to remove a sin for this emotional scene
of rick and morty breaking up but
instead i'm removing one because i
appreciate that this show has taught me
to not give a [ __ ] about anything that
happens in it shutting off emotions is
healthy thank you rick and morty thank
you watch sitcoms on your sneakers can
you imagine the amount of neck problems
that would exist if this became a
reality did the chiropractor guild
sponsor this segment
is this friendship i think so
candy citizens
we are going to war
i have crossed the horizon to find you
that that's how we lost our cable guy
well maybe i shouldn't have come at all
jerk off
stop those poor boys that's what they'll
call us
[Music]
wait
are you my father
no but i stole your egg and mutated your
brain wow somebody's been busy i did it
because you hurt my feelings i learned
it by watching you